[Musique]
wordpress
on est en approche
je préfère
notre sept convois attention à 15
obama ces gamins et en difficulté dégage
mollo sur la haine la noce
le protégerait contre câble est tout
seul je peux pas faut du renfort
on va former un super méga groupe mais
on va refaire un tour sur linkedin je
représente date là je m'appelle shatter
star domino j'ai de la chance la chance
c'est pas super pouvoir écouter sida
mais si on n'a qu'à couper la poire en
deux et non aller en piste
donc moi
tepa héros
indiqué qu'ils aient enjoint tellement
d'arc
tu es sûr que tu viens pas l'univers dc
comics
je
[Musique]
sans mal grand jeu wii le bordel
dis donc t'es mal elles sont rapides
maintenant pour couronner le tout peter
un super pouvoir quelconque je sais pas
nager pas de pouvoir non j'ai vu
l'annoncé voilà tel poste
[Musique]